PROFESSOR: We are still
in chapter 12 on
the sum-product algorithm.
I hope to get through that
today, fairly expeditiously,
and to start with chapter 13.
The handouts for today
will be chapter 13.
And, as usual, problem set 9
with problem 8.3 has been
moved up into problem set 9.
Problem set 8 solutions
for 8.1 and 8.2.
So I'm going to start off on a
different tack of presenting
the sum-product algorithm.
Where is everybody?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9.
Is there any competitive event
that I should know about?
I know the traffic was bad and
it's a rainy, late morning.
Problem getting here myself.
Well, this is improving.
The write up of the sum-product
in the notes is in
terms of equations.
And I've never been terribly
satisfied with this write up.
It's concise, but we have to
invent some new notation,
which I don't consider to be
completely transparent.
I've never found it particularly
easy to present
in class, and it's been a little
frustrating to me.
So I'd like to try a
different approach.
I'd like in class just to go
over through a very explicit
example, our favorite
844 code.
What we're trying to achieve
with the sum-product algorithm
and how the sum-product
algorithm helps us to achieve
it in an efficient way.
So it's proof by example.
It won't be very satisfying to
those of you who like to see
real proofs, but that you can
get by going back and
re-reading the notes.
So I'm going to try doing it
this way and you will let me
know by your looks of gladness
or of frustration whether you
like it or not.
So let's start at the
beginning again.
What are we trying to do?
We're trying to compute the a
posteriori probability of
every possible value of every
symbol, internal and external,
that appears in a graphical
realization for a code.
And we will consider these
to be APP vectors.
In other words, if a symbol is
eight valued, there will be
eight APP values
in the vector.
And we're going to assume that
we have a cycle-free graph
realization, so that we can
proceed by the cut-set idea to
solve independent parts
of the graph.
And at the very end, we'll relax
that and see whether we
can still do OK.
All right, one concept that
seems very simple in theory
but that some people don't get
till they really try to do it
in practice is that an APP
vector is really a likelihood
weight vector normalized so
that the sums of all the
probabilities are equal to 1.
For instance, if we send plus
1 or minus 1 through an
additive white Gaussian Noise
channel with sigma squared
equal to 1 or whatever, then
the probability of--
we call this y and this r, the
probability of r given y
equals whatever.
This is probability of r given
y, is 1 over square root of 2
pi sigma squared e to the minus
y minus r-squared over 2
sigma-squared.
And so we can compute that
for y equals 1 and y
equals minus 1.
And we'll get a vector
of two things.
The APP vector would then
consist of this evaluated for
y equals 1.
Let me just take this part of
it, a to the minus r minus 1
squared over 2 sigma squared
and e to the minus r plus 1
squared over 2 sigma-squared.
Something proportional to these
two vectors normalized
and that's why I continue to
use this proportional to
symbol, which you may not
have seen before.
Or maybe you have.
So the APP vector in this case
would be proportional to--
well, actually 1 over square
root of 2 pi sigma-squared
times each of these
two things.
But this would basically tell
you how much weight to give to
plus 1 and minus 1 as possible
transmitted symbols.
And all this matters --
there's one extra degree
of freedom in here.
You can scale this, the whole
vector, by any scale factor
you like and it gives you
the same information.
Because you can always normalize
the two terms to be
equal to 1.
So if this, for instance, was
0.12 and this was 0.03, that's
equivalent to 0.8 and 0.2.
Two probabilities.
Actual a-posteriori
probabilities that sum to 1,
all you've got to do is
keep the ratio right.
This is four times as large as
that, so what that really
means is 0.8 and 0.2.
And in implementation, so the
sum-product algorithm, we
never really worry about
constant scaling factors.
As long as they appear in every
term we can just forget
about scaling.
I mean we don't want things to
get too large or too small, so
we can apply an overall
scaling factor.
But as long as we've got
something, the relative
weights, then we have what
we need to know.
Let's go to the 844 code since
we know that very well and ask
ourselves what it is we're
trying to compute.
We're given APP vectors for
each of the eight received
bits, let's say.
We transmit y, we receive some
r, perhaps over an additive
white Gaussian noise channel.
So we get a little 2 term APP
vector for each of these y's,
telling us the relative
probability that a 0 was sent
or a 1 was sent.
That's called the intrinsic
information.
Let me just call that.
So for each one we
get p0 and--
let me make it p0 and q0, the
two terms for y0; p1 and q1
for y1 and so forth.
So we have that information
for each of
the received symbols.
What's the likelihood of each of
these code words then given
these individual bitwise
likelihoods, the probability
of the all zero code word.
It's likelihood, let's say, is
then proportional to p0, p1,
p2, p3, p4, p5, p6, p7.
Whereas the probability at 1, 1,
1, 1, 0, 0, 0, 0 is q0, q1,
q2, q3, p4, p5, p6,
p7 and so forth.
Each one is a product of the
eight corresponding terms.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You're assuming that
the bits are independent.
PROFESSOR: Yes, it's a
memoryless channel.
So the noise in every symbol
transmission is independent.
And that's important too.
AUDIENCE: So basically once
again, the second bit is
independent of the first
bit in transmission?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry,
I was writing and I
missed what you said.
AUDIENCE: Well, I mean, if the
first bit is 0, maybe that is
a code where if the first
bit is 0, the second
bit has to be 0.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, there's
certainly dependencies among
the code words.
That's what we're trying
to take into account.
This is how to take
it into account.
So I'm assuming a memoryless
channel.
But I'm of course, assuming
dependencies within the code.
How do I do that?
One way is maximum likelihood
decoding.
What do we do when
we do maximum
likelihood decoding in principle?
We exhaustively computed each of
these 16 products, each of
these 16 likelihoods for each
of the 16 code words.
We'd simply pick the one that's
greatest and that's the
code word that is most likely
to have been sent.
So that's what exhaustive
maximum likelihood decoding
consists of, finding the maximum
likelihood word.
And that clearly takes into
account the dependencies.
We're only considering
valid code
sequences when we do that.
In APP decoding we're doing
something else, but it can be
characterized quite simply.
What's the a-posteriori
probability that say, the
first bit, is equal to a
0 or is equal to a 1?
We can get the APP by summing up
the likelihoods of all the
code words that are associated
with the value of the bit that
we want to see.
So we take the eight code words
that have a 0 in this
place and we'd sum up these
likelihoods for those eight
code words, and that would be
the weight, the likelihood
weight of y0 being 0.
And the likelihood weight of y0
being 1 would be the sum of
the other eight.
And again you see that
scale factors aren't
going to matter here.
All we want is the relative
weights of these things.
So that's what we're trying to
do in APP decoding, but we're
trying to do it now for
every single variable.
At this point, I've only shown
you the symbol variables, the
external variables.
So a brute force way of doing
that would be to fill out this
table, all 16 likelihoods, do
these sums and then we'd have
the APP vector for
each of these.
Now we're looking for a more
efficient way of doing this.
The efficient way of doing this
is going to be based on
the fact we have a cycle-free
graph realization.
Which in this case, is a
trellis realization.
I'm going to use this two
section trellis where each
section is a four-tuple.
We've drawn it two
different ways.
This is a very explicit way
showing the two parallel
transitions that go from the
initial node to the central
state, and then two
more down here.
The set of code words
is the set of all
possible paths through--
corresponds to the set of all
paths through this trellis.
So for instance, includes the
all zero word, (0,0,1,1,1),
(1,1,1,0,0,0), (1,1,1,1,1,1,1),
and so forth.
And these I happened to have
listed as the first four here.
Or we now have this more
abstract way of writing this
same thing.
This says there are four
external variables and two
state variables or a vector
space of dimension 2 here and
a vector space with
dimension 4 here.
That the dimension of this
constraint is 3.
That means there are eight
possible values for these
combinations of 4 and 2.
They're shown explicitly
up here.
And they form a linear
vector space.
Either way, this is our
trellis realization.
Now, we know that to do maximum
likelihood decoding,
it's useful to have this trellis
realization, because,
for instance, we can do
Viterbi decoding.
And that's a more efficient
way of finding what the
maximum likelihood
sequence is.
Basically, because we go through
and at this point we
can make a decision between
0, 0, 0, and 1, 1, 1, 1.
We only have to do that based on
this four-tuple and then we
can live with that decision
regardless of what else we see
in the other half.
And likewise in the
other direction.
So now we'd like to use this
same structure to simplify the
APP decoding calculation,
which looks like a more
complicated calculation.
So how do we do that?
We introduce two state
bits here.
All of these have state
bit 0, 0, 0, 0.
Sorry, this point, we've
called this state 0, 1.
Just to keep it visually
straight, 0, 1, 0, 1, 0, 1,
and then there are eight more
corresponding to the other two
possible values of the
state bits over here.
This is a quaternary variable.
We want it to assume that it's
a four-valued variable and to
make the realization cycle-free,
I don't want to
consider it to be two
independent bits.
So there are four
possible values
for this state variable.
So maybe I just ought to call
this my state space --
which is a four-valued
state space.
Now, what's the a-posteriori
probability of the state
being say, 0, 0?
I compute that in
the same way.
I compute that simply by
summing up the four
likelihoods of the code for the
external variables, the
code words that are associated
with state variable 0, 0 --
the first possible values of
this quaternary variable.
So it'd be the sum of
these four things.
Yes?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: I've only listed
half the code words.
This is only 8 of the
16 code words.
You want me to write
the other 8?
And by the way, there's at least
an implicit assumption
here that the code sequence
determines the state sequence.
As we found when we did minimal
trellis realizations,
the code sequence always does
determine the state sequence.
So if I know the entire code
word that also tells me what
the values of all the
state variables are.
There's a 1:1 correspondence
between code words and
trajectories in a
minimal trellis.
And I believe I'm sometimes
implicitly using that
assumption.
But anyway, it holds whenever
we have a cycle-free graph.
In a cycle-free graph, we have
a well-defined minimal
realization.
And the minimal realization does
have this 1:1 property.
So the state variables
are determined
by the symbol variables.
Suppose I want to compute the
values of these state
variables here.
Let me write this out.
This will be p0, p1,
p2, p3, q1--
sorry ---
q4, q5, q6, q7.
And then there's one
that's all q's.
q0, q1, q2, q3, q4,
q5, q6, q7.
So basically, what I want to
do is take the sum of these
four things, and that's just a
sum of products and I could
just do it.
But the Cartesian product lemma
gives us a simpler way
of doing it.
We notice that I can have
either of these two
four-tuples as the first half
and either of these two
four-tuples as a second half.
In fact, I see over here,
explicitly, these four code
words are the Cartesian product
of two four-tuple
codes, the repetition
code on 4.
So I can use the Cartesian
product lemma to
write this as --
again, let me write it
very explicitly.
p0, p1, p2, p3, which you
recognize as the probability
of this four-tuple plus
q0, q1, q2, q3.
The probability of this
four-tuple times p4, p5, p6,
p7 plus q4, q5, q6, q7.
Now do you agree that the
product of those two terms is
equal to this, the sum
of these four terms?
Yes, there are four terms
in this sum and
they're what we want.
And it's because we have this
Cartesian product structure,
which we always have
in the state space.
This is the basic Markov
property of a state variable.
So that's a simpler
calculation.
This requires four
multiplications, each one is
seven-fold multiplication.
This only requires one multip --
well, it requires one, two,
three, four-fold
multiplications, plus one
overall multiplication.
And it's certainly a simpler
way to compute that.
And I can similarly do that for
each of these down here.
What this leads me to is what
I called last time the past
future decomposition.
We have one APP vector over here
that corresponds to the--
let's call it the APP vector
of the state given the past
received symbols.
We had something like that.
In other words, given what was
received for y0, y1, y2, y3,
what's the probability, the
partial a-posteriori
probability for each of the four
possible state variables
given this past?
And similarly, we have another
vector which I will consider
to be a message coming in this
direction, a message
consisting of a vector
of four values.
Which is what's the probability
the state vector
given these four received
simple, which is computed in
the same way?
That's this here.
And the past future rule is
that just the overall
probability for any of these
internal state variables, the
overall APP vector, is just
obtained by a component-wise
multiplication.
This would be the APP of the
state vector being equal to 0,
0 given the past.
This would be APP of the
state vector given
0, 0 given the future.
We'd have the same thing
for 0, 1, 1, 0, 1, 1.
And to get the overall APP
vector given all of r, the
rule is just multiply
them component-wise.
We take the likelihood weight
for 0, 0 given the past and
multiply it by likelihood
weight of
0, 0 given the future.
And that gives us the total
likelihood weight up to a
scale factor.
The notes derive this
in equation terms.
You see it basically comes from
this Cartesian product
decomposition, which we
always get for any
internal state variable.
The possible code words
consistent with that state
consist of a certain set of
possible past code words
consistent with that state.
Cartesian product with a set of
possible future code words
consistent with that state.
And as a result of that
Cartesian product
decomposition, we always get
this APP vector decomposition.
That's what the proof
says in the notes.
Do you like this
way of arguing?
A couple people are
nodding at least.
It's an experiment.
All right, so that tells us what
we're going to want to
do, at least, for the
internal variables.
And actually, the same
is true up here.
The variables going
in are easy.
That's just p0, p1, p2,
p3, or whatever.
The ones coming out are--
this is called the intrinsic
variable, the one that we get
from direct observation,
the intrinsic APP
vector, excuse me.
The extrinsic APP vector is the
one that we get from all
the rest of the inputs and
symbols and the other
parts of the graph.
And we combine these
component-wise to get the
overall APP vector.
All right, but we now
have to do this for
every part of the graph.
Let me go through another
calculation, which will--
how do we, for instance, find
the APP vector for y7, the
extrinsic APP vector for y7,
given that we have a
trellis like this?
In general, for y7, we're going
to be adding up all the
zeros, these guys.
And four more down here, and
we'll make that the extrinsic
APP vector of 0.
So we want to add up this and
this and this and this and so
forth, eight of those.
We want to do that in
an efficient way.
This defines a code word with
eight possible components.
Let me move this up now.
So let's talk about
this 6, 3 code.
What does it look like?
With state vectors 0, 0,
I can have y4, y5, y6,
y7 be 0, 0, 0, 0.
Or I can have it
be 1, 1, 1, 1.
The state vector is 0, 1.
I can have 0, 1, 0, 1 or I
could have 1, 0, 1, 0.
With state vectors variable
1, 0, I can have 0, 0, 1,
1 or 1, 1, 0, 0.
And with 1, 1, I can have 0, 1,
1, 0 or 1, 1, 1, 0, 0, 1.
All right, so that's
precisely the 6, 3
code I'm talking about.
Now suppose I have the APP
vector for each of these.
The APP vector for each of
these, 0, 0 we've already
calculated.
It'd be p0, p1, p2, p3
plus q0, q1, q2, q3.
That's the likelihood vector for
0, 0 coming from the past.
So that's one part of
this message here.
For either of these I get
p0, q1, p2, q2, q3
plus q0, p1, q2, p3.
Reflecting the two possible ways
I can get to this value.
I'm going to get four terms
that I've computed for the
past message.
I'm going to have four
likelihood weights
corresponding to each
of the four values
of this state variable.
So I've got that vector.
I already computed it as part
of the computation to do the
APP for here.
It's the past part of it.
So now, I want to compute the
probability that y7 is a 0.
The rule here is to take every
combination in this code and
again, I'm going to get a--
well, let me write
this part of it.
This is going to be
p4, p5, p6, p7.
That's the probability
of this four-tuple.
This is q4, q5, q6, q7.
This is p4, q5, p6, q7, q4,
p5, q6, p7 and so forth.
That's the weights I want to
assign to each of these.
So now I get a weight for each
of these six-tuples.
I multiply this by this to get
the weight, the likelihood
weight, for this code word.
This by this to get the
likelihood weight for this
code word and so forth.
And I add these to
buckets for--
I simply go through this and
I'll add this one to the
bucket for y7 equals 0.
And I'll add this to the
bucket for y7 equals 1.
And this to the bucket
for y7 equals 1.
And this to the bucket for
y7 equals 0 and so forth.
It's clear that in this bucket
I'm always going to get the
same value for p--
I'm always going to get a
p7 for 0 and a q7 for 1.
So just looking at y7, I don't
have to compute the seventh
value here.
So if I did this separately as a
little y7 variable, then the
incoming message, the intrinsic
information, would
just be this p7, q7 likelihood
weight vector.
And what I really want to
compute is the outgoing part,
which has to do with
y4 through y6.
So let me draw it that way.
This I don't think is very
good exposition.
Bear with me.
So now I'm going to put this
times this in my bucket for 0.
This times this in my bucket
for 1, and so forth.
The question here is, does this
method give me the same
answer as my exhaustive
method up here?
And again, because of the
Cartesian product character of
the states, you can convince
yourself that it does.
In other words, I can use this
as a summary of everything in
the past that got to the state
value equal to 0, 0, 0.
Any time I got to 0, 0,
0, I got through one
of these two things.
And so for any possible
continuation over here, I
could have got to it in
one of these two ways.
And I'm going to find terms,
e.g., these two terms.
Let's see.
What do I want?
I want two ways of getting
to 0, 0, 0.
I'm sorry, these two.
I claim that this times
these is equal to the
sum of these two.
And it is.
I can get to 0, 0, 0, 0, 0
either through this or this.
And I get to 1, 1, 1, 1, which
is this one, either through
this or this.
And again, it's a fundamental
property of the state that
whenever I get one of these, I'm
going to get both of them
in equal combination.
So I can summarize things in
this way, which leads to an
efficiency of computation.
So what I'm basically explaining
to you now is the
sum-product update rule, which
is how to propagate messages.
Propagating messages, which
are APP vectors.
In general, my situation is
going to be like this.
I'm going to have some
constraint code, (n,k), I'm
going to have some incoming
messages over here which tell
me about everything that's
happened in this past, p
prime, and in this
past, p prime.
Give me a summary of all the
weights corresponding to that.
I'm going to have some output
symbol over here and I want to
compute now what the APP vector
is for the possible
values of this output symbol,
which is going to be some
aggregate of this down here.
What I do is I go through all
2 to the k code words, call
this constraint code.
Sorry, I'm using k again.
That's 2 to the k code words.
And compute the product
of the inputs.
Of input APP vectors according
to the possible combinations
of the input variables and the
output variables that are
allowed by this constraint.
That's explicitly what
I'm doing here.
Here are all the possible
combinations of state
variables and symbol variables
that are allowed by this 6, 3
constraint code.
There are eight of them.
For each one, I'm going to
compute the relevant product
of APP vectors and I'm going
to add it to a bin.
So add to a bin.
Bins which correspond to--
draw it like that--
output.
I'm calling this the output
variable values.
OK, and that'll give me the
summary APP vector of the
outputs for now the past, which
consists of everything
that could have happened in
this side of the graph.
Again, I'm using the cycle-free
assumption in
several ways.
I'm saying that everything
that happens up here is
independent of everything
that happens here.
Everything that happens
completely in this past is
just the sum of what
happens here.
What happens here are subject
to this constraint and has
nothing to do with what happens
over here in the future.
Eventually I'm going to do the
same thing in the future.
I'm going to compute a future
component that's based on all
this stuff.
I'm going to get messages going
in each direction and
I'm going to sum them up.
OK, now I'm seeing a fair
amount of puzzlement on
people's faces.
Do you get abstractly what
I'm trying to do here?
Does anyone want to ask
a clarifying question?
So now--
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
the bottom right,
output variable?
PROFESSOR: Output variable
values, I'm sorry.
I think there's a little bit
of confusion here because
sometimes I've considered
this output to
be a 16-valued output.
Here, in fact, well, it has
eight actually valid values.
And if I was considering it that
way, then I would just
have one bin for each of
these likelihoods.
But now if I consider these as
four binary variables, then I
would aggregate these things
according to the values of
each of the binary values.
And I'd get four vectors
of length 2 for
the individual APP.
Which is ultimately what I want
here, so I'm sorry I've
gone back and forth between
subtly different realizations.
I do find this very
hard to explain.
Perhaps there's someone else
who can do a better job.
You have a homework problem
which asks you to do this, and
I think having done that you'll
then get the idea.
But it's a matter of going back
and forth between the
gross structure and the
actual equations and
just working it out.
All right, so the key things in
the sum-product algorithm.
I've already explained
some level to them.
We have this sum-product
update.
That basically explains given
messages coming into a node,
how do we compute the message
going out of the node?
We take contributions, products
corresponding to what
the code allows.
We dump them into the
appropriate bins in the output
vector and that's the
sum-product update rule.
We have the past future
decomposition
or combination rule.
And that says at the end of the
day, you're finally going
to get messages going
in both directions.
And you just combine them
component-wise as
we started out with.
And finally, we need to talk
about the overall schedule of
the algorithm.
So let me draw an arbitrary
cycle-free graph.
OK, suppose I have an arbitrary
It consists of external
variables out here, internal
variables and constraint
nodes.
How am I going to schedule these
computations in order to
do APP decoding of this graph?
Well, what do I have
at the beginning?
At the beginning, I measure
the received variables
corresponding to each symbol,
and that gives me the
intrinsic information, which
is incoming message you can
consider from every
symbol variable.
Basically, what did I
see on the channel?
That's what that likelihood
weight vector corresponds to.
All right.
What do I need in order to do
the sum-product update rule?
I need the inputs.
Think of this now as
a directed graph.
I need the incoming messages on
all of the incident edges
on this node except for one.
If I have all but one, I can
compute the last one as an
outgoing message.
So that's the structure
of that update.
So at this point, can I
compute anything here?
No, I would need the inputs.
But I can compute this
outgoing message.
I can compute this
I haven't drawn these
of very high degree.
Normally we have degree
higher than two.
If I had another input here,
however, I could still get
that output.
All right, so that's time one.
Think of there being a clock
and at time one I can
propagate messages
into the graph to
depth one if you like.
There's going to be a systematic
way that we can
assign depths.
All right, now at time two
what can I compute?
I can compute this guy because
I have this input.
Now I have both inputs
coming in here, I can
compute this guy.
Anything else?
So maybe 0, 1, 2.
I should put times
on each of these,
so I don't get confused.
0, 0, 1, 0.
So this is 2 at the output.
Now I'm at time three,
what can I compute?
At time three, I now have two
inputs coming in here.
I can compute this output.
Actually, from these two inputs,
I can compute this
output at time three.
And from these two, I can
compute this outgoing message
at time three.
Are there other things
I can compute?
Can I compute this?
No, I don't have this yet.
That's probably it.
Does anyone else see anything
else I can compute at time
three based on the time zero,
one, and two messages?
No.
All right, but I'm
making progress.
And should be clear that I'm
always going to be able to
make some progress.
At time four I can compute this
message in that direction.
Let's see, I now have everything
I need to compute
this message in that
direction.
And I'm almost done.
And finally, I can compute this
message in this direction
at time four, the extrinsic
information for those variables.
I guess I can do this
at time four.
I had that at time three.
And now at time five, I can get
everything else that I need.
Time five I get that out.
I get this out based on this
input and this input.
And I get this out based on
this input and this input.
So in a finite amount of time,
in this case, five
computational cycles, I can
compute all of the messages in
both directions for every
variable in the graph.
Now as a final cleanup step, I
simply component-wise multiply
the vectors in the two
directions, and that gives me
the APPs for all
the variables.
This is a kind of parallel
computation of all the APPs
for all variables
in the graph.
And I claim two things.
It's finite and it's exact.
And the exactness is proved
from the equations and the
cycle-free assumptions.
So we can always decompose
things as Cartesian products.
Independent components.
The finiteness, well, I assumed
this is a finite graph.
What is this number 5?
It's really the maximum length
of time it takes me to get
from any of these external
symbol variables
to any other external--
from leaf to leaf in
graph theory terms.
And that's called the diameter
of the graph.
And again, some people count
the last little symbol node
and some people don't count the
last little symbol node.
But it's clear that a finite
graph is going to have finite
diameter and that the
propagation time is basically
going to be equal
to the diameter.
That's how long it takes to
get across the graph.
So each of these messages
in each direction
has a certain depth.
That's the distance in
the graph to the most
distant leaf node.
And the maximum sum of these
is always going to
be 5 in this case.
Notice that it is.
A tiny little graph
theory theorem.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
you see why if you sum these
messages flying through those
past and future of the single
edge, you would get the
overall APP because you're
summing the contribution from
both the set of outputs and
those [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
How would you prove that that
should be overall the APP of
the symbols?
PROFESSOR: Recall the
state space theorem.
Let's take any edge in here.
Suppose we think about
cutting it.
A cut-set through that edge.
Suppose we consider
agglomerating everything back
here and calling
that the past.
Agglomerating everything
out here and
calling that the future.
This is past and future.
The idea of the state space
theorem was that this is
exactly the same situation
as a two section trellis.
Because everything is linear
you get the state space
theorem basically, which says
that you get a Cartesian
product of a certain past,
a certain future.
You get a minimal state
space, which is kind
of the total code.
The modulo, the part of the code
that lives purely on the
past, and the part that lives
purely on the future.
That quotient space is really
what it is, corresponds to the
state space at this time.
Because every edge in a
cycle-free graph is by itself
a cut-set, you can do this
for every edge in
any cycle-free graph.
You can make this
same argument.
So you get a well-defined
minimal state space.
You get a Cartesian product
decomposition, which has a
number of terms equal to the
size of the state space, due
to the dimension of the state
space over binary field.
And so everything goes through
just as it did
in the trellis case.
That was the argument.
So mushing all this
together, you get
the sum-product algorithm.
This is the fundamental reason
why I took the time to go
through minimal trellis
realizations of block codes.
Not because that's actually the
way we decode block codes
all by themselves, or even
use block codes.
We use convolutional codes.
It's so that we could prove
these very fundamental
theorems about graph decoding.
And we aren't even going to
decode cycle-free graphs.
But that's the intellectual
line here.
Thank you for that question,
it was very well timed.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Let's take a look
at the structure of this.
Where do the computations
occur?
Every node there's
a computation.
What's the complexity
of that computation?
It's somehow approximately
equal to the size of the
constraint code.
We do one thing for every
possible combination of
legitimate combination of
variables, which is what we
mean by the size of the
constraint code.
So if this is a 6, 3 code, we
need to do eight things here.
Basically, eight
multiplications.
So this, in more general
cycle-free graphs, that's what
corresponds to branch complexity
and trellis graphs.
We found that the branch space
corresponded to a constraint
code in trellises.
So the computation is basically
determined by the
constraint code complexity and
really, overall what we'd like
to do is minimize the constraint
code, the maximum
size of any constraint code
because that's going to
dominate computation.
So we try to keep
the k in these
things as small as possible.
Yes?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
and you get larger dimension
constraint for
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, we're actually
not too concerned
about diameter.
Because things go up
exponentially with constraint
code dimension, just that single
parameter tends to be
the thing we want to focus on.
But we remember that's hard
to minimize in a trellis.
We showed that basically our
only trick there after
ordering the coordinates was
sectionalization and that we
could not reduce the constraint
code complexity,
the branch complexity,
by sectionalization.
And then again, we build on that
and we went through this
argument that said, gee, this
corresponds to some trellis.
We could draw a trellis where
this, literally was the past
and this was the future.
And the minimal size state space
in this cycle-free graph
would be the same as
in that trellis.
What I guess I didn't show
is you can't reduce the
constraint code complexity
by significantly --
actually, I'm not sure there's
a crisp theorem.
But the fact that you now are
constrained to size of state
space, this is certainly going
to be at least as large as
state space sizes.
Tends to indicate that you're
not going to be able to do a
lot about constraint code
complexity by going to more
elaborate cycle-free graphs than
just the chain trellis
graph either.
That's, I think, a missing
theorem that
would be nice to have.
I had a paper about a year or
two ago, I'm not sure it ever
quite gets to that theorem.
But that's the theorem
you'd like to see.
You really can't improve this.
So ultimately, we're bound by
what you can do in a trellis.
And in a trellis you can't do
too much about this branch
complexity parameter once
you've ordered the
coordinates.
A bit of hand-waving here, but
we're going to need to go away
from cycle-free graphs.
One reason I like normal graphs
is that you get this
very nice separation
of function.
You get the idea that nodes
correspond to little computers.
You could actually realize this
with little computers.
Put a computer in here
for each node.
Its job is to do the sum-product
update equation.
And then, well, what
are the edges?
They're for communication.
These are the wires that run
around on your chip.
And so when we talk about state
space complexity, we're
really talking about something
like bandwidth.
How wide do you have to
make these wires?
Do you have 6 bits, or
9 bits, or whatever?
So state space really has
to do with communication
complexity.
Constraint or branch has to
do with the computational
complexity, which sometimes
one's more
important than the other.
Computational tends to be
the thing we focus on.
But we know more and more as
we get to more complicated
chips, communications
complexity
tends to become dominant.
And this, of course, is the
I/O. These are your paths
which go to the outside
world, your I/O paths.
So it's really a good way
to think about this.
And in fact, some people like
Andy [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
and his students have
experimented with building
analog sum-product decoders.
The general idea here is that
you can compute an output as
soon as you have the two
corresponding inputs.
Well, imagine another schedule
where this thing just computes
all the time based on whatever
inputs it has.
In a cycle-free graph, say
you're in the interior.
Initially, what you have on
your inputs is garbage.
But eventually, you're going to
get the right things on all
your inputs.
And therefore, you're going to
put the right things on all
your outputs.
So again, up to some propagation
times, just
putting in non-clocked little
computers here, whose function
is to generate the right outputs
given the inputs in
each direction, is eventually
going to be right in a
cycle-free graph.
And in fact, there are very
nice little analog
implementations of this where
it turns out the sum-product
update rule is extremely
amenable to transistor
implementation nonlinear rule.
So you just put these in, little
computing nodes, and
you put whatever you received
on here as the received
symbols, and you let it go.
And it computes incredibly
quickly for
a cycle-free graph.
Where we're going to go is we're
going to say, well, gee,
we got this nice little local
rule that we can implement
with local computers for the
sum-product algorithm.
Maybe it'll work if we do it
on a graph with cycles.
And on a graph with cycles
this kind of parallel or
flooding schedule, where every
little computer is computing
something at every instant of
time, is probably the most
popular schedule.
And again, you build an analog
implementation of that and it
goes extremely fast and it
converges to something.
It just relaxes to something,
there's a local equilibrium in
all these constraint nodes.
And therefore, some global APP
vector that satisfies the
whole thing.
I think this is a nice attribute
of this kind of
graphical realization.
All right, a particular
example of how
this schedule works.
The cycle-free realization
that we care most
about is the trellis.
The BCJR algorithm is simply
the implementation of the
sum-product algorithm
on a trellis.
SP on a trellis.
So generically, what does
a trellis look like?
I guess I should allow for some
nontrivial code here.
So all trellises have this
same boring graph.
What is this schedule?
It's a cycle-free graph, so we
could operate according to
this nice controlled schedule,
compute everything just once.
And how does that operate?
We get intrinsic information
that's measured at each of
these symbols here.
What did we receive
on the channel?
We put that through a constraint
code and we get
here, let's give this a name.
This is called intrinsic 0.
Here is alpha 1, which is just
a function of the intrinsic
information at time zero.
And we combine that with the
intrinsic information at time
one and we get alpha
2, and so forth.
So we get a forward-going
path down the trellis.
If any of you knows what a
Kalman filter or a smoother
does, this is really exactly
the same thing.
This is finding the conditional
APP probabilities
of this state vector given
everything in the past.
In Kalman filtering or
smoothing, it's done for
Gaussian vectors.
Here we're talking about
discrete vectors.
But in principle, it's doing
exactly the same thing.
It's computing conditional
probabilities given everything
observed in the past.
And so the diameter here
is just the length
of the trellis basically.
So this is i n minus 1, i n.
And here we have alpha n.
When we have alpha n finally
in here, we can compute the
extrinsic information based on
alpha n as just extrinsic n.
We combine these two and we're
done for that guy.
Meanwhile, we have to compute
the backward-going information
on each of these branches.
So we compute first
b n based on i n.
Then we get b n minus 1
based on i n minus 1
and b n, and so forth.
We get a backward-going
propagation of conditional
information.
Each of these betas represents
the a-posteriori probability
vector given the
future from it.
And finally, when we get down
to here we can compute
extrinsic 0 from data 1.
And by this time, when we have
both alpha 1 and beta 2 coming
into here, we can, of course,
get extrinsic 1.
When we get both the alpha and
beta coming in here, we can
get extrinsic 2, and so forth.
Of course, you can write
this down as equations.
If you want to read the
equations, you look in the
original Bahl, Cocke, Jelinek,
and Raviv article in 1973.
This was again, a kind of lost
paper because just for
decoding a trellis, the
Viterbi algorithm
is much less complex.
And gives you approximately
the same thing.
I mean, I talked last time how
probably what you really want
to do in decoding a block code
is maximum likelihood.
That's minimum probability of
error in a block-wise basis.
What APP decoding gives you
minimum probability of error.
If you then make a decision
based on each of these
extrinsic information, or on the
combination of these two
to get the overall APP vector,
that's called a map algorithm,
maximum a-posteriori
probability.
If you make a decision based
on that, that will give you
the minimal bit error
probability, but it may not
necessarily give you a code
word, and it will not minimize
the probability of making any
error, which is generally what
you want to minimize.
So for trellis decoding
of block codes
this was not favored.
However, a block code as a
component of a larger code,
you want the APP vector to feed
off to something else.
And so with the advent of much
larger codes, of which block
codes are components or
convolutional codes, BCJR is
the way you want to go.
And some people say it's about
three times as complicated as
the Viterbi algorithm.
All right, so you'll have an
exercise with doing that in
the homework.
There is a closely related
algorithm called the min-sum
algorithm, or the max-product
algorithm.
And the idea of that is that you
can really carry through
the same logical computations
except when you get to one of
these combining operations,
rather than doing a sum of
products, you can do
a max of products.
And that the Cartesian product
law still holds, the same kind
of decompositions that
we have still hold.
For instance, in this example,
to get the state 0, 0, 0
before what we said we're going
to get an APP vector
where this is the past APP for
the 0, 0 value of the middle
state vector.
We simply combine the likelihood
weights of the two
possible ways of getting to that
state and we sum them.
Instead of doing sum,
let's just take max.
The maximum probability
of getting--
in other words, what's the
best way of getting here?
Same question as we ask in
the Viterbi algorithm.
We'll let that be the likelihood
weight for the
state vector.
Otherwise, the logic is
exactly the same.
Similarly, coming this way,
what's the max of these two?
OK, what's the best way of
getting to the state vector in
terms of likelihood
from the future?
And what do you know, if we
combine these things at this
point, we now have a past vector
and a future vector.
Let's take the max of this
times the max of that.
That gives us the maximum
likelihood way of going
through the 0, 0 value
of the state.
If we do exactly the same
logic for decoding this
trellis, we get a two-way
algorithm.
It's like this.
It's like the BCJR algorithm,
where at every point we're
computing the maximum
likelihood.
It's not hard to show that what
this gives you is that
each of these symbols out here,
it gives you the symbol
that belongs to the maximum
likelihood code word.
How does it differ from
the Viterbi algorithm?
It gives you the same answer.
It gives you the symbols, one
by one, of the maximum
likelihood code word.
It doesn't have to remember
anything.
It doesn't store survivors.
That's its advantage.
It's disadvantage is it's
a two-way algorithm.
You have to start from both
ends and propagate your
information in the same way.
And for block codes,
maybe that's OK.
For convolutional codes that's
certainly not something you
want to do because the code word
may go on indefinitely.
So the Viterbi algorithm gets
rid of the backward step by
always remembering
the survivor.
It remembers the history of
how it got to where it is.
So that once you get the max,
you don't have to--
you simply read it out
rather than having--
this backward part amounts to
a trace back operation.
That's probably much too
quick to be absorbed.
But I just wanted to mention
there is a max product
version, which if you take log
likelihoods becomes a max-sum.
Or if you take negative log
likelihoods it becomes min-sum.
So this is called the
min-sum algorithm.
And it does maximum likelihood
decoding
rather than APP decoding.
And sometimes it's used as
an approximation or very
intermediate approximations
between these two.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: No, if you use the
min-sum, basically everybody
will converge on the same
maximum likelihood code word.
So all these constraints will
be consistent with--
you'd be taking a single
max at each point.
But at each point you will
solve for the maximum
likelihood code word.
And what you'll see up here is
the symbol that belongs to the
maximum likelihood code word.
This is maybe a bit of a miracle
when you first see it,
but you'll independently get
each of the bits in the
maximum likelihood code word.
Check it out at home.
AUDIENCE: Why not
always do this?
PROFESSOR: Why not
always do that?
It turns out that we want softer
decisions when this is
part of a big graph.
We actually want the APPs, the
relative probabilities of each
of the values.
The max, in effect, is making
a hard decision.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, all right.
It does give reliability
information.
I'm not sure I can give you a
conclusive answer to that
question except APP
works better.
That's a more empirical
answer.
Yes?
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
Where does that flexibility
of the input symbols being
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
We should be able to take
that into account
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
OK, well, if the input symbols
are independently not
equiprobable, you can
feed that in as--
you know, once they came out
of the channel, once we see
the channel information,
the two symbols are not
equiprobable anymore.
So if somehow they a priori
independently were not equally
probable, you could just feed
that in as part of this
intrinsic information vector.
That's almost never the
case in coding.
The intrinsic information is
sometimes regarded as a-priori
and this has a-posteriori, or
the combination of the two of
them is then a-posteriori when
this goes off somewhere else.
But it doesn't really mean that
the symbol itself was--
it means that the evidence is
biased one way or the other.
And when this appears somewhere
else in the graph,
this will now appear somewhere
down in some other graph.
It's called the a-priori
information, but what it is is
the a-posteriori information
given all of the received
symbols in this part
of the graph.
AUDIENCE:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
Does the i0 of that other
graph contain this table
sharing information
added to it?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the i0 for
another graph is just the e0
of this graph.
I mean, if you consider it
all as one big graph,
that's what you want.
You want the message that goes
in this direction, which
basically summarizes all of the
inputs from this graph.
Generally, you'd have a little
equals node here.
You'd have the actual intrinsic
information coming
from the outside world there.
You would compute the
e0 from this graph.
And at this point, you would
combine e0 and i0, and that
would go around here.
So the very last page of chapter
12 just says, OK,
we've got a nice, clean, finite
exact algorithm that
will compute all these APPs
on a cycle-free graph.
Now, suppose we're faced with
a graph that has cycles.
And here's the situation.
Suppose the graph has
cycles in it.
Then first thing that might
occur to you, at least after
this development is, well, we
now have a local rule for
updating at each of these
computational nodes, each of
these constraint nodes, in
this representation.
Why don't we just let it rip?
See what happens.
We're going to put in some
intrinsic information at the
outputs as before.
We can compute some output
message here based on-- well,
eventually we're going to get
some input message from here.
And we can compute some output
message here based on all of
these and we'll pass
that over.
Let's assume what's called
a parallel schedule or a
flooding schedule, where in each
cycle every one of these
little guys does its thing.
It takes all the inputs that it
has available at that time
and it generates outputs.
Well, hope for the best.
It will compute something.
You can sort of intuitively
see that it'll settle.
It'll converge, perhaps, into
some kind of equilibrium.
Or hopefully it will converge
into some kind of equilibrium.
There is a basic fallacy here,
which is that the information
that comes in here is used to
compute part of this message.
Which is used to compute
part of this message.
Which ultimately comes back and
is used to compute part of
this message.
And then part of this message
again, so that information
goes around in cycles and it
tends to be used again and
again and again.
Of course, this tends
to reinforce
previously computed messages.
It tends to make you
overconfident.
You heard some rumor and then
the rumor goes all around the
class and it comes back
and you hear it again.
And that tends to confirm
the rumor.
So it's that kind of telephone
situation, and it's not really
independent information.
Intuitively, makes sense
that if all of the
cycles are very large--
in other words, the rumor has to
go to China and back before
you get it.
That it probably is highly
attenuated by
the time you get.
It's mixed up with all kinds of
other information, so maybe
it doesn't hurt you too much if
the cycles are very large.
And in fact, that's the way
these capacity approaching
codes are designed.
Whereas, as I mentioned last
time, if you're in a physical
situation where basically your
graph looks something like
this, you don't have the freedom
to make your cycles
large, then this is probably
a bad idea.
And this isn't why in fields,
like vision, for instance,
people try to use this--
the sum-product algorithm is
the belief propagation
algorithm, if you've
ever heard of that.
Widely used in inference
on Bayesian networks.
And the religion in belief
propagation used to be that
you simply can't use belief
propagation on graphs that
have cycles.
Why?
Because most of the
graphs they dealt
with look like this.
And in fact, it works
terribly on that.
It was a great shock on that
field when the coding people
came along and said, well, we
use belief propagation on
graphs with cycles and
it works great.
And this, as I understand it,
really had an enormous impact
on the belief propagation
community.
But it was realized that gee,
coding people have it nice.
You make your own graphs.
And you make them so this is
going to be a very low order,
low impact event.
And that's right.
But coding we do have
this freedom to
design our own graphs.
We realize from the basic
arguments that I put up before
that we're really going to
need to have cycles.
As long as we have cycle-free
graphs, we're going to get
this kind of exponentially
increasing complexity, which
is characteristic of
trellis graphs.
So we're going to need cycles,
but as long as the cycles are
very long and attenuated, as
long as the girth of the graph
is great, maybe we can
get away with it.
And that, in fact, is the way
the story has developed.
And Gallager basically saw this
back in 1961, but it took
a long time for it to catch.
So I didn't even get
into chapter 13.
Chapter 13 we're going to first
just introduce several
classes, the most popular
classes of capacity
approaching codes.
And then I'm going to give
you some real performance
analysis, how you would design,
simulate, in these codes.
And it's what people
actually use.
OK, see you next time.